Max uh back-to-back victories in Bishop
and games as well almost last to finish
today also there's something about those
bishop and games yeah go read the book I
guess but uh yeah I mean those are rare
I was knocking myself for going into
this one though because I missed the
king F6 uh route I will I was also I saw
the king d65 but then I'm winning with
Bishop Jade H7 but when he played King
F6 I was like my God I saw that
preliminary and then it went into it I
was like what did he get then I met then
I decided to play H5 to have a chance
but and you're talking about this moment
when yeah when I could have just kept
the minor pieces on with like a huge
Advantage I think but who knows at this
point yes yeah Knight takes and Bishop
to C4 just just keep moving the king and
yeah that's there's Knight D5 move wow
king plus two really
that is pretty amazing
but he did equalize
at this point perhaps not King to Eve
Bishop C4 I thought about that but
Bishop C4 yeah I'm not sure about that
because what's there I wouldn't trust
this engine yeah I'm not right trusting
well G4 F4 G4 oh my goodness okay that
yeah that had
yeah I lost my focus here because I just
I couldn't believe what I did
so I was uh I was not looking at these
like long-term things you know I'll just
yeah and this I don't know what's the
quality it was this moment when he
played the move H5 if he goes H6 then
the game is more or less a draw right
now yeah I can figure that so C5 yet and
then and then King F4 and Bishop E6 and
you just and then like if I swing to the
to the there's no way to swing in yeah
there's no swinging yeah
unswingable yeah H6 I saw that a year
and I was like I was even thinking of
temporizing to force like H6 and then
maybe H5 but I saw like another move
that black could play yeah yeah so
believable yeah but you know oh yeah C7
is not winning yeah C7 King E5 and then
swing at this point yeah she's seven
King E5 and then what happens Bishop C8
only move okay Bishop B8
there's probably a lot of only moves
coming up right King B6 only move it's a
question who's first right yeah and it's
and it's equal yeah if he runs yeah and
it's just it's oh that I'm even lost oh
yeah he wins a couple Tempe going to the
Deep one yeah
not easy to calculate yeah no of course
but wow and towards the end of the game
I mean we saw okay
after this move H5 did you realize that
finally you have something to work with
I thought I'm just winning here but yeah
but um uh and you are and I am but it's
just uh it's just sad it's sad that I
went into the bishop pending and it's
also sad that it's still probably
winning after King uh whatever Bishop C4
but that's such as chess and
such is stress indeed but still
back-to-back victories that must feel
quite good despite the fact that maybe
you missed a couple of things here and
there yeah look it's things are working
out for you right so far second yeah
yeah keeping peace with uh Malik so
absolutely yeah it's a two-horse race it
feels like right now well at least after
the process is still here guys any
questions
first of all our congratulations to you
Max I noticed that you had gone over to
the game of Joel Benjamin for a moment
did you point out a tactic to Joel or
because there was this moment in Joel's
game that there was a very cute tactic
yeah I thought rookie won yeah but then
he said Knight F5 is fine so instead of
Queen G7 because I thought Queen Q7 was
a little scary no I don't think it was
that moment yes sir but that was the
that was the moment there was I mean we
were referencing because there was this
moment I had to find the the moment yeah
early in the opening this was the moment
he had Knight C2 which finishes
[Laughter]
I did not see that move that is a thing
of beauty yeah
oh my God no it felt like black should
be winning but uh yeah I mean
good stuff our congratulations Max very
nice he scores three and a half out of
four to keep pace and it's the